hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well from the very
beginning of his speech all the way
through to the end
Eric's amicus in praising love is
actually going to be praising his art
his Technic his skill of Medicine he's
going to say that this provides us with
the key to actually understanding what's
going on with love and what the previous
two speech makers Pausanias and
Phaedra's have hinted at but not quite
gotten a clear idea of and so he's going
to say that the technique of medicine
provides us with the lens through which
we can understand the workings of love
and as we're going to see in other
videos this is going to extend
throughout the entire cosmos understood
and rather physicalist terms here we're
concentrating primarily on medicine as
applied to the human body because that's
the that's the metaphor that he's going
to use to understand all of this so Eric
silicon says that we can understand love
by looking at bodily health and sickness
he says the body admits of both good and
bad love the same thing that puffs arias
was talking about now health is the good
love health is when the parts of the
body are actually working well with each
other
and they are different parts right think
about all of your organs and the various
you know systems that you've got you
know nervous system circulatory system
there's a lot of as we say moving parts
and all those parts have to cooperate
with each other or else there's going to
be problems so you know sometimes if one
part works harder than it should that
can cause problems for all the other
parts so in a certain sense health is
this this state of a kind of equilibrium
in which things are all going the way
that they're supposed to the physical
processes are working the way that they
should what health has another aspect to
so it's it's good love but it also
involves good desires so if you want to
stay healthy and your body does want to
stay healthy there are certain things
that you need to keep doing like eating
and drinking and you know getting some
exercise and perhaps sunbathing you know
if the ozone layer isn't depleted like
it is for us all these sorts of things
right there there are certain limits
within which one would would you know do
these sorts of things you don't just eat
everything whatsoever all the time or
you're going to be unhealthy that leads
us to talking about disease so disease
is the opposite of Health and notice
that opposites are going to play an
incredibly important role for Eric
Symmachus not only at the sort of bottom
basis level but at what we might call
metal levels or organizational levels
where its entire complexes of things
that are that are opposed to each other
fundamentally but are either brought
into some sort of harmony with each
other or are you know in some sort of
discord with each other in any case
disease represents a state of the body
in which the body itself is a unity but
it's not a unity that is working well
it's not a unity that is entirely
harmonious it's divided against itself
things are not working as they should
you know if we think about this we're
thinking about Plato here if we think
about this in Psychological terms then
we would have play those parts of the
soul that going
you know combat each other until they're
properly harmonized here Eric Symmachus
is thinking about the organs of the body
and the things that compose those organs
now of course they didn't have a you
know a cellular theory at that time they
thought of the organs as being composed
of some matter that was roughly
understood in terms of you know basic
elements and we're gonna we're gonna get
to that account in just a moment in any
case what's important to think about
about disease as opposed to health is
that disease not only represents a
disordered condition of the body it also
introduces in the person who feel who is
diseased new desires which are unhealthy
desires diseased desires so the person
who has you know there's this disease
that they call dropsy where you would
just keep drinking you know water over
and over again because you kept on
feeling thirsty and eventually you would
you would die of that that's a bad
desire to have because it's not going to
you know produce health in the body so
when you're diseased you don't think
about the sort of things that you want
to do and you're feeling sick you just
want to lay around do nothing if you
have those desires all the time that
would be a problem right so there's
opposition's between health and disease
not only in the way that they're
composed or or decomposed but also in
the desires that they have and although
Erikson MCUs doesn't make this
completely clear we can also think of
desires in a sense of producing health
or producing disease right not only does
does being healthy tend to give you good
desires to want to remain healthy it
also is a product of following good
desires not eating too much but eating a
certain amount not drinking too much but
drinking a certain amount we could talk
in terms of mental health you know not
going out and doing every single
possible activity but doing some
activities having some desire for social
interaction likewise there are some
desires that are going to be unhealthy
in the
in that they not only tend to be the
things that that people who are
unhealthy feel and are motivated by but
if you if you're healthy and then you
have those sort of desires that are
going to lead to disease sooner or later
you're not going to be healthy so you
know think about here's an example not
one that Eric Simic gets gifts but one
that would work very well for this think
about what goes on with addiction too
you know particularly pleasurable drugs
you you know you try out something and
you find that while this really feels
good and now you've got this desire and
the question is is this a desire that's
going to lead to health or is this a
desire that's gonna lead to disease
you know I'll use one that I can relate
to quite well which is nicotine right or
well caffeine is another great example -
it's not good for you to drink two pots
of coffee a day which is something that
I often do but it's pleasurable is that
good for the body over over time and you
know it's it's something that's probably
conducing to some level of disease right
makes it harder to sleep at night you
know we could run through all sorts of
things so you know if you are originally
healthy and then you follow out an
unhealthy desire sooner or later you can
end up being diseased you know the flip
side of that you could say that part of
what we try to do is steering people
away from diseases to health is to get
them to do the sorts of things that will
actually make healthy life desirable for
them the inculcate new desires and Eric
Seneca says that what the the art of
medicine consists in he tells us to two
sets of things that are important one I
put here the ins and outs of the body
all right he talks about you know
filling and repletion right we might say
you know putting things in the body
taking things out of the body so you
know the body is is a whole network of
things that are constantly flowing
around and things are
and things are growing out so you know
very much depends on what you're putting
into the body right if you're smoking
two packs of cigarettes a day probably
be healthy for very long you know if
you're eating too much you're eating in
our own time this was a huge problem in
Greece at the time of Eric's immigrants
but if you're eating a lot of processed
food probably not going to be very good
for you right on the other hand if
you're eating food that you know
actually is healthy a balanced diet
you're going to be preparing your body
for being in a healthier state you know
we can think of all the other things
that we put into our body and then
medicine also looks at what comes out of
our body you know are we sweating
excessively you know they would look at
people's excretions of various sorts
they'd look at urine and stool samples
back then just like your doctors do now
you know if there was blood coming from
things and the blood looked kind of
weird they do wonder you know why is
this blood looking this way you know
like let's say you get a wound or
something and and your blood congeals
way too quickly that might be a sign of
a problem right so medicine is a technic
is interested in the flows within the
body and how to make them work right now
this this pans out in what it's
functions are Erickson Macca's talks
about quite a few things that medicine
is able to do and of course he's
praising his own art here under the
guise of praising love but he says that
that medicine can produce good or
healthy love you know what would be an
example your doctor tells you to go on a
diet change your behavior which will
lead to a different state of your body
and now your organs they actually work
better you know you don't get winded
going up the stairs you got to put some
exercise in with that as well but you
know you can multiply examples with this
right reduce bad or unhealthy love
within the body banner and healthy love
is where we're attracted to the things
that are good for us and where our
you know parts of our body are kind of
warring against each other you know the
doctor in Eric's amicus's time might not
just be concerned with with diet he
might be concerned with what we call
work-life balance you know that could be
a good example where the doctor says hey
you need to you know take a vacation
replacing one of these with the other
obviously the good doctor is going to
replace bad lung or unhealthy love with
good love although you know they know
how to how to switch these things around
so if your doctor has it in for you you
could find ways to make you say and then
he says something really interesting
Eric's amicus gives you the impression
that one of the things that the art of
medicine is able to do is to allow us to
a certain extent to enjoy you know some
of the benefits some of the pleasures of
unhealthy love without incurring all of
the penalties or the consequences of it
it lets us do a little bit of that so
great example of this Eric Symmachus
says what's that drink to excess guys
he's actually called by by one of the
other interlocutors you know by Elsa by
days at the end almost sober son of a
most sober father right so this is
something that his father also was a
doctor so this is something that the
doctors sort of keep in mind this is
what it's able to do now let's talk
about how Eric Symmachus represents this
is coming about
he has a what we can call a metaphysical
account of things and in this
metaphysical account with the body and
then as we're gonna see this applies to
just about everything because this is a
physicalist account there are these
elements and these elements are
opposites which naturally are in a state
of conflict with each other when we use
this term elements and we're talking
about ancient Greece most people are
going to think about the four element
theory with you know earth air fire and
water
perhaps the fifth element the
quintessence which is ether added to
that as well Erickson Magus is going to
drill that out even further
he says that these opposites these
ultimate elements are things like
metaphysical principles the hot versus a
cold the wet versus the dry and he also
brings up one that has to do with taste
which is quite interesting perhaps other
types of perception the sweet versus the
bitter translated in some of the texts
as sweet versus sour but it's really P
gross or bitter he thinks that these are
metaphysically basic and because they're
opposites they're always in conflict
with each other trying to over master
each other you know caught in certain
cycles and so within the human body all
of this stuff is going on and if things
don't go the way they're supposed to
pretty soon the human body is going to
break down any sort of body will any
sort of composition of these will break
down so what the art of medicine is
supposed to do is to introduce healthy
love and he calls this a you know
Concord or harmony where he you might
say in very basic terms getting a line
not getting along in the sense of light
liking each other necessarily but in the
sense of respecting certain limits and
being able to take turns and harmonize
with each other
that's what healthy love within the body
does it super imposes this structure
upon the elements that are opposites in
conflict and thereby provides a higher
unity so that's what medicine is really
all about
according to Eric Symmachus the art of
medicine applies to this and thereby you
know uses these sorts of concepts in
these sorts of activities to do its work
now all of this is supposed to be under
the aegis of the God of love but notice
what Eric's amicus has actually done he
has made love in both the good in the
bad form something that is the object of
the art something that is worked upon
by the tech name of Medicine